i love you i love your wigs
i love red
i was going 80s with my liner and
everything congrats you just had a son
right since the last time i saw you yeah
[Music]
so that's is that six girls and one boy
i got six girls and one boy yeah you got
there you got that box oh man ain't that
something yeah more pampers yeah is that
what y'all were doing you were like it's
gotta be a boy at some point yeah you
know after you after you a man and you
have six daughters you're like wow
and now i'm 51 so
i get a lot of estrogen it is and and my
son is going to be walking around with
80 year old dad at the game
so you know my son forced me to take
care of better better care of my health
now because
is that the truth i got to be there for
all the kids oh my god that's a lot
though six girls that's amazing so you
took your youngest daughter was it
disney on ice is that you took her to
disney all night was that fun i had more
fun than her i think
okay because i've never been i had never
been either my kids have been and they
loved it but i just love how in awe she
is the whole time yeah she's just
sitting there loving it the whole time
i enjoy disney on ice i mean you know
you get a chance to watch the kids enjoy
themselves and and like i said it's a
good show for an adult if you ain't
never been i've never yeah i've never
been you know the ice skating and the
moana comes out they got the lights and
have you ever ice skated i'm like just
staying up it's hard for me just like
not falling i'm always really impressed
by people moving around on a little
bleed yeah yeah it's hard it's hard i
know i got a lot of junk in the trunk
item
so let's talk about the special it's
hilarious i love that you were like play
that again i appreciate it so it was
filmed in indianapolis so what's it like
to perform at home do you love that or
you get nervous it was tough performing
and you know i decided to do it
because i wanted to you know every time
i come back home they're like man when
you gonna do something for us cause i'm
always doing specials in other cities so
i said you know what i'm gonna do one in
my hometown
and i was so excited and happy and man
when i walked out on that stage and i
seen all my childhood friends
i seen my lawyers and
cops that chased me before you know when
you see your lawyer are you worried
about what you're going to say
[Laughter]
laura's like don't i gave him a shout
out in on the show i gave him his name
is jeff ball when i gave him a shout out
i said everybody give it up for jeff
baldwin he saved me from doing 20 years
and he stood up we're crazy
he's like you're welcome
and he called me he called me the next
day he called me the next day he said oh
man my phone is ringing off the hook
everybody want me to uh represent them
now
you say something like that that's
amazing so wait we both grew up during
the 80s so what were your favorite parts
of the decade did you love the music
man i love the music man we used to have
a a a show that came on friday night in
indiana called night tracks and they
played all eight with an x a night
tracks with an action
yeah they were cool yeah yeah and they
played man they played uh
bruce springsteen they played played uh
uh uh uh uh what's her name uh grace
jones yeah yeah i got introduced to a
lot of music from the 80s that you know
it's like yeah 80s music was the best i
feel like too like radio was more broad
like you could hear like so many
different kinds of artists on one
station yeah yeah i like that british
music i love that's why people like you
know a lot of my black friend they're
like man how you know all this
white music night tracks
night tracks night tracks with an x yeah
yeah they knew what was that that's a
rhinestone cowboy yeah exactly
you just didn't know i knew that i know
but you know that and grace jones and
bruce springsteen they're all on the
same channel that's amazing and i know
pooh scheisse you ever heard of that
that sounds like something else it's a
wrap
sounds like something else maybe it's a
different name where you grow up i don't
know um
it's a family show sorry i took it there
um so so before we go what advice would
you give me i'm entering my 40s i'm
excited oh yeah yeah cause i feel like
when i turned 30 i was like i have a
little figured out this is so great i'm
getting older and at 40 i feel like i'm
like it's awesome because i know i don't
have it figured out and that's like fine
it's like yeah well you know what you
you about to be 40 that mean you are
seasoned yes experience experience i
liked it wise right yeah but you still
too you still i'm a child
yeah you still got a childhood so that's
a great age you know what i mean 40 is i
feel like it's going to be good it is
yeah and then at 51 yeah
you think you're running faster
in your mind but your body ain't running
fast dude
i was doing that the other day
it's different i was running but my mind
was running faster than my body
everyone yeah everyone keeps telling me
about that and it's like my eyesight
that's the thing like i had lasik
surgery done when i was like 20 and so
i've like 20 20 but i've noticed
literally you go just now it's like what
like i can't my eyes the visioning thing
is happening and that's not cool that's
right i think i'm gonna look sexy in
some readers though
yeah i'm gonna make really look real hot
hey kelly you're gonna look good
anywhere you go i'm gonna make some sexy
librarian readers it's gonna be so good
how are you gonna do y'all i'm gonna i'm
gonna turn all the men on at the geritol
convention it's gonna be so good very
tall it's gonna be good all right thank
you so much mike i appreciate it thank
you
so funny mike will be part of netflix is
a joke the festival on may 5th so go
online right now for tickets y'all gotta
check that out also be sure to watch his
comedy special it's called mike epps
indiana mike and it's streaming on
netflix as well
[Music]
you